the carnegie mellon electors
Center which started in tooth
one is there because electricity is
critical to American competitiveness and
all of our research is designed to make
sure that the electricity that we have
in the future is reliable and that it
meets the needs of the public and what
we've been doing is we've probably been
trying to figure out how what are the
crucial needs of the industry not just
in the immediate run but trying to take
more longer run we're looking at the
ways to produce electricity without so
much carbon dioxide going into the air
and what are the pluses minuses all of
the various ways for example we've taken
a look at capturing carbon dioxide from
a power plant and putting a deep
underground that's something nobody else
in the country is looking at we believe
will be able to shape the regulatory
environment so we have to figure out
some way in which we are going to
generate this electricity in a more
sustainable way and so we've been
looking at biofuels we've been looking
at a number of renewable resources
including wind solar and so on trying to
figure out how it is they're going to
fit into the mix to produce electricity
that's reliable of high quality and
that's going to be affordable
you